we live in a world that doesn't offer
our personal prized possessions the
security of always being saved the good
news is you can take matters into your
own hands with a little innovation if
you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and give this video
a big thumbs up today we are discussing
ten secret hiding hacks that will fool
the smartest burglar DIY hide-a-key
everyone knows about the key safe that
looks like a rock so having a random
rock on your porch isn't going to do
much to protect from burglars
but there is a way you can hide your key
using a rock that will go undetected try
the DIY hide a key hat all you have to
do is glue a fake rock to the top of an
empty plastic bottle then once the glue
is dry place your key inside of the
plastic bottle and bury so that only the
fake rock is showing no one will ever
suspect there is a key under such a tiny
rock hidden outlet safe if you are
unfortunate enough to have someone break
into your home you might be able to
still outsmart them by hiding your
valuables and unsuspecting places you
lessen the risk of having them taken one
of the best hiding hacks is the hid and
outlet safe no robber is going to take
the time to check every outlet in your
house if you have an outlet in a
hard-to-reach spot then consider easily
converting it into an outlet save sneaky
keyboard almost every house has one but
how often do people still use the
keyboards the rise in popularity of
laptops have made standard keyboards
almost obsolete
so why not turn your old unused keyboard
into a sneaky safe for a larger storage
space hollow out the whole keyboard but
make sure it still looks functional for
a smaller safe space hollow out the
numerical keypad on the right and keep
the rest of the keyboard intact no one
will ever suspect a thing
keys on a wire if you are crafty and
also want a troll potential burglars at
the same time try the keys on a wire
hack can you imagine a robber trying to
go through dozens of keys while trying
to figure out which ones unlock your
door not only will this alarm neighbors
but it would also take forever for this
hack you will need a bunch of dummy keys
and of course your real house key next
tie the keys together so that they form
a wind chime if they do find the key
then they almost deserve whatever is
inside DIY door top stash have you ever
looked at your door and thought it could
do so much more for you yeah ice neither
but take another look because you can
actually hide small belongings inside
your door and put the deal
why door top stash you need a wooden
door and the ability to hollow out a
hole on the top edge once you make the
hole use a metal container to keep your
valuables in and slide it in the hole
you can later retrieve your belongings
put the magnet and feel like MacGyver
while doing so bathroom tile storage
those people don't think of their
bathrooms when they want to hide
valuables it's for relaxing and cleaning
up not for storing prized possessions
but there is an easy way to hide your
precious goodies without anyone being
the wiser just try the bathroom tile
storage hiding hack all you have to do
is remove a tile or two and replace it
with a tiny storage unit with a tile
glued to it for camouflage if you have a
bathroom with a lot of tiles then it
would be nearly impossible for anyone to
find unsuspecting lettuce how many
burglars will rip apart a head of
lettuce hoping to find something
worthwhile inside the answer is none
which makes the unsuspecting lettuce
hack brilliant you can actually buy a
storage container that looks identical
to a head of lettuce for a hundred
dollars the price will set you back a
bit but it's better safe than sorry
once you get your sneaky lettuce safe
place it in the fridge with your
belongings and hope the robber doesn't
get hungry for a sandwich
DIY holo-book thanks to movies and TV
everyone has seen hollowed-out books it
may seem like an obvious choice but if
you have a lot of books the holo-book
hack might work you can easily buy
hollowed-out books at craft stores or
online or you can make one yourself the
process takes a while but it's really
easy all you have to do is purchase a
cheap old book and then use a box cutter
to cut a storage space a few pages at a
time then hide your valuables inside and
place it on the bookshelf next to your
regular books air vent fault kit thanks
to the show Dexter people that started
thinking outside of the box when it
comes to hiding their valuables the show
made hiding things in an air vent so
popular that one company now makes fake
air vent bolts you can purchase an air
vent vault kit and install it into your
house yourself they look exactly like a
regular air bed so no one would ever
have a clue what goodies you have inside
you can make it extra safe by placing it
high on the wall near your ceiling
deodorant sticks - if you are low on
cash but still have things you want to
hide try the deodorant sticks - it's so
easy and unsuspecting that it's
surprising it's not well known all you
need is a stick of solid deodorant to
make this hack work once you have the
stick of deodorant remove
actual deodorant from the compartment
and then cut the deodorant in half next
place your stash inside the empty
compartment and place the deodorant back
on top to conceal it you now have a
handy hiding place that can go wherever
you go are you going to try any of these
secret hiding hack react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things